the satanic temple has set up a display
of a sparkling demonic Rams Head in the
Iowa State House as an expression of
religious freedom alongside more
traditional minoras and Christmas trees
the groups say has erected an altar
topped with candles a large banner and a
ram figure with skull covered in mirrors
a Red Cloak and a wreath the temple
reportedly went through all the correct
administrative channels for the display
and only had their original request to
use a real goat's skull denied so there
was no attempt to turn them down or
anything like that or to fight over this
they were just given exactly what they
wanted aside from putting you know the
carcass of an actual animal in the state
housee but everything else they got
Satanism is a mockery of Christianity
specifically it is not a valid religion
unto itself